on any given day
you should probably be sending
thoughts and prayers to my husband
because this man has the patience of an actual saint
and if you've been following any of this series
you will know that this room has been torturous
but let's be honest
it's probably been torturing him more than it's been torturing me
and today just for shits and giggles
I thought we could torture him together
with the world's most difficult sheers
The sheers normally? not that hard
but in this room? extremely fkn problematic
because we have a raked ceiling
but low window heights
and weird measurements and other things
that I don't care to understand anyway
so we've got the same freedom S fold sheers
in the dining room
which is the room off this one
which has an extremely high ceiling
so in that room they're perfect
but in this room
we pretty much needed to cut them in half
and also cut all the tracks
but the fabric comes with these little strips
so you can just cut them to size
iron that on hang them and then you’re away
it's super easy apparently
I don't actually know cause I was no help at all
my job was to be the tester for quality  control
and I can confirm they passed
but this white rug unfortunately did not pass the vibe check
I absolutely adore this rug
it's thick it's cosy
I'm gonna pop it in my daughter's room but for now
the dimensions are just all wrong
there's a bit of a backstory and maybe I'll tell you one day
but the long and the short of it is we needed a bigger rug to fit this space
because this side of the room has kind of a weird layout
it's pretty long but pretty skinny
and I'm not sure if you've noticed
but my couch is enormous
somebody even commented and said it was too big
and you could be right but also all we do here is sit
and I could either have a ton of extra floor space
or a ton of extra ass space
and I chose the ass space, obviously
cause there's five of us and we often have guests
and we all need somewhere to sit anyway
the new rugs centred it all really nicely
and I promise you'll get the full reveal in the next part